[Music]
Stephen I want you to draw me like one
of your french girls holding this
holding
only this okay double help with the
ringers
[Music]
[Music]
last thing I need is my face on another
t-shirt tacitly implying my
homosexuality this would be the way to
do that as a first not gaping member
mclubbe I expect to get what I want
okay if you go over on the bed from the
casting couch but not get couch the
straight cash just to just get get in
the couch put them up by your face a
little bit right over to you
no not not by your whiskers can can you
a chess set
yeah no no put it back put put no put it
back yeah put it back okay no eyes on me
eyes on them up put the get eyes off me
put them on them on keep keep the eyes
in the mud okay perfect don't look me in
the face so serious
[Music]
oh I believe you to be blushing mr.
late-night you can't imagine Trevor Noah
blushing
he's a just relax your face
no laughing Jimmy Kimmel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the party at Joe Rogan's
house how many will talk about a Nick
DiPaolo infinite just discovered the
naturally occurring chemical in your
mind it's 4:20 every day I'm so glad I
loved loved Joe he's gonna be on the
show I think you sometimes you know
actually we'll be back either you'll be
with me on the Joe Rogan show or bill
Richman and talk about the youtubes and
the illegal stuff hold on we haven't run
it we have great guests today we have
Nick DiPaolo who just fired from Sirius
Radio for what I think is a perfectly
acceptable tweet and then we have Dave
Rubin who never know what he's gonna say
don't
Entenmann's generally he doesn't
surprise you hops twins as well not to
mention the hot twins yeah we have the
hot wings a little cameo from the
hodgetwins and if sad we could bring up
my mic a little bit I don't know why I'm
hearing myself like I'm in it's talking
in a pool which is silly producing with
me in video studio as always as Jared
who is not gay sounds great follow him
on Twitter not gay Jared Anita's credit
with the comment you thought you
Photoshop self a family obligation sorry
on conclusions are we good am I not gay
after that sketch I haven't no I don't
know anymore surely right you're not
doing yourself any favors love and then
we have Somalia simplified wine.com
G Morgan Jr what's the one of the day
yeah black Sears Zinfandel black Sears
infant out I feel like a Sears that sets
up in an urban demographic I don't know
it sounds like a terrible bottle of wine
and wine we have a computer you ready
for the overlays I'm ready for the
overlay someone to give a shout-out to
the Twitter account
that's my he went back to like oh yeah
we're just not gonna renew his work visa
and hopper camp question of the day
before we move on what do you think
about the Kanye West situation we're
going to be talking about that more so
about the idea sort of black Democrats
as a monolith at large and the backlash
from the media question number two how
many people out there are a long time
enough listeners that you remember Kanye
as our bump music and here's a link just
to confirm what was the bump we use one
specific Kanye about our the last
segment before the drowning dance before
we went on YouTube and then we got hit
with the Capri right Felisa Nomura Khan
you have always said the guy's an ass
the very talented emcee yeah not bad
alright well listen top story Bill Cosby
was found guilty oops the sexual assault
retrial comedian Bill Cosby is comes
from HuffPo just because we can take the
story from anywhere don't kiss early
trust them
don't take it as a vote of confidence
found guilty on three felony counts of
aggravated indecent assault really the
indecent and that seems he was retried
on three felony counts of aggravated
indecent assault for drugging in
basically is there a decent yeah what
would that be I don't know I'm sure that
must have been all now if you drug
himself in that one or any people are
see often did that's the thing he
drugged both of them he just had a
higher tolerance it was like a game of
chicken with a bug through it
don't play with Roman Polanski so many
are saying that this is a landmark case
obviously for victims of sexual assault
now some are arguing that it doesn't go
far enough and punishing the sort of
pervasive mail abuse of power
however with unilateral agreement that
the ruling will definitely hurt
pre-orders for mr. Cosby's dating tips
it he's so old at this point is he
really like is he really a troubled
threat to society at this point he's
gonna break a hip in the shower he's
gonna be a rough go someone will break
his America he's going to jail for this
I'm just like ah what the doctor knows
America's dad it was a fight with your
family doctor doctor Huxtable yeah he
was a family doctor but imagine sending
your kids at that die everybody well you
saw a lot of pregnant women too so I'm
just saying made a lot of pregnant women
too oh they just weren't aware hello the
British Veterinary Association by the
way is now warning that dogs cannot get
autism as the anti-vaxxer movement is
now apparently spreading the pets this
comes from the Telegraph the BVA said we
are aware of an increase in anti
vaccination pet owners and us who have
voiced concerns about vaccinations that
may lead to their dogs developing autism
like behavior but there is currently no
scientific evidence to suggest autism
and dogs or a link between vaccinations
and autism
well tell that to my dog who will
exclusively fly Qantas ok and of course
this actually might put a damper on
Disney's new Christmas release Air Bud
19 buddy places for that the special
olympics
oh this explains a lot of behaviour to
me you know extremely loud necrotic loss
may have been a serviceable film if it
was a dog dead of that annoying kid
throw
Dean Cain you got a classic I just
wanted to swallow Tide Pods 13 semis big
trucks lined up on a Detroit freeway to
help a man who was considering suicide
so I think we have a clip right you have
a clip yeah there was a man on top of
the bridge authorities believe he was
about to take his own life they start to
grab semi drivers and troopers standing
there and were able to line these semi
trucks underneath that overpass
so it's kind of like a safety net to
make sure if he moved anywhere there was
a semi their valiant effort
unfortunately their valiant efforts
proved futile as Detroit has actually
just installed the suicide lane on their
freeway so he helpful the mark those
there's so many flat holes in this by
the way fun fact for Detroit faster than
the police response time it seems now to
people committing suicide is the other
guy at the end of the CB radio from joy
rock Detroit's a city incumbent we have
loads of burning coffee houses and
inspiring art districts the answer rain
washes everything no one in the pitch
room aside from Johnny boy had seen joy
Ron is true that the candy cane yeah
yeah okay point in some days you just
you just pick the wrong bridge in
Detroit every bridge is the wrong bridge
to nowhere it's the bridge to rape which
is another bestseller from kolakozhi
suicides the fastest way fun fact to get
out of choice well you know if you're
looking for the bus just just don't it's
just much easier to walk into downtown
without a bulletproof vest that's the
easiest way by the way breaking news
it's hashtag lesbian visibility day this
has been trending all over the place
because it's a slow news week so the
pink news they released their list about
you know their lack of visibility for
lesbians and how to help them how to
raise availability visibility in society
for lesbians and then of course some
people aren't necessarily as capable at
spotting lesbian so let me let me
consolidate the list for you simplified
version if she drives a Subaru
out back wait I tried to date a girl if
there's if there's more than one bumper
sticker you know she's it's not mark
yeah more than one bumper sticker on a
Subaru Outback also if she eats it out
back careful I'm gonna drive my shooby
to get price I am I have been so I have
to shave a lot when we do a lot of these
costs when we do costume my stuff so I
have to get razors that I can shave
quickly and change my hair and I gave
Jarrod my old trimmer when I got a new
trimmer recently and I'm excited about
it and I gave it to him I was like hey
man take this as a it's been a great
trusty trimmer to me and the problem is
I got I didn't realize a new one just
totally gnarled up my face yeah and I
wanted to ask Jared if I could trade him
the newer more expensive one because I
have like hairs that grow if I can trade
but I felt so I didn't want to be an
Indian giver that I spent like a hundred
and fifty dollars finding one from
another country of the old version the
first operation because it's the
titanium blades they don't do it anymore
well here's the thing you better be glad
he didn't give it back he does his
manscaping with the one you gave him I
made a mistake and regretted it Hey
a transgender inmate sued a prison to
practice a North Carolina prison who
practice witchcraft I'm trying to think
of the way to set it up that provides
context so you can and I can't Maine a
man says in her his handwritten federal
lawsuit that Landsborough Correctional
Institution is blocking the practice of
her his spiritual beliefs which happened
to be rooted in witchcraft though some
are saying you know listen if you've
seen orange as a new black some people
try to work the system and actually
there's been a recent special with an
interview from some of this transgenders
inmates who questioned the story welcome
I know I've heard of no damn worker
what's that witchcraft man oh damn
witchcraft man oh that damn screaming I
have a cadaver bush pulling you down she
was doing
oh look at that hey you rooms this won't
you turn that nice sweet yours into some
nice hot whip I need some nice sale yeah
that's a good idea be all kinds of magic
I'm going first what you know what
they're half white I would not want to
run into them in prison you never seen
prison throw more more into [ __ ]
anyways yes sir burnovich trapped there
just tough you know what I mean like a
grandfather was jailed after servicing
himself in front of his podiatrist this
is a story comes from Salle's break
we're Salsbury son computer where is
this Salsbury Connecticut I think it's
in Britain Britain
oh is it written has to be thank you
very much you should know these things
and write these things a grandfather who
service themselves comes from the
Salsbury journal in front of a
podiatrist while she treated his
veruca's I think that's the thing
varicose and cut his toenails denied the
indecent exposure but admitted
pleasuring himself during a foot health
appointment and it's Dick Morris ah
why specify grandfather that's that has
let's say like uncle pee-wee Herman
service himself in a theatre line if it
weren't yeah I know the grant for that
it adds that extra layer of oh she's
touching my feet oh it's the umami of
clickbait hey by the way hit the
notification bell if you're watching
this on youtube up hopper can he's
getting up he decides he wants to leave
right now right as we're doing all right
like screw it done I hit the
notification bell because he's huge
docks and apparently by the way people
aren't getting notified even if they
have enough even live elsa hit the bell
the rhuebottom's news and make us go buy
a west and kind of explain the whole
thing but a massachusetts preschool has
now banned kids from using the term best
friend this comes from ABC 7 after an
incident with the four year old Julia
Hart well the school explained to Hart
well that the term best friend can lead
other children to feel excluded and it
could ultimately quote lead to formation
of cliques and outsiders and the school
encourages students to have a wider
quote group of friends was explained to
the transgender kids from the
transgender principal from the girls
bathroom
let's get rid of best friends this is
the front we're the best teachers and
best schools and best principals as well
writing but the fact is that's why
teachers unions exist it's show yes yes
sure if he a good teacher we don't want
him just put him in a trauma room leave
him alone truth is without exclusion who
safety that's the only thing that's the
only sentient for kids not to be giant
a-holes ya need you need a little
exclusion it's all social pressure well
you know that very well because you were
homeschooled in but I was not no he was
no he was and his mom wouldn't
breastfeed her uncle Wow and it was a
footlocker shih tzu what the podiatrist
in there go it was a private story so
Nebraska by the way has finally stopped
horsing around from this headline and
it's actually legalizing massage therapy
for horses equine massage therapy thanks
to a newly signed bill Nebraskans no
longer need to license themselves to
massage cats or dogs or horses the bill
was actually spurred on by Karen Hoff
who began massaging horses at her farm
in central Nebraska as a way to become
financially more stable after being
issued a cease-and-desist she was forced
to shut her business down she then
pushed for the new law which has now
just been passed this now a lot though
some suspect ulterior motives at play
given her notorious business partner Sal
the horse groper people thought he might
have been impure I'm confused people
didn't want to massage horses and cats I
guess an example of red tape I mean he
can massage it as long as she's
massaging the cat like under water for
about 30 minutes just make sure did you
imagine that can you picture a in asian
massage parlor for horses I an Asian on
a horse have you ever seen agent which
do you know or not I didn't think about
today they don't even need a train to be
talkies they could just dominate that
market it's written that's true just put
him on a show horse let him go let me go
for it awesome I'm loose we're terrible
Knicks Apollo is definitely not getting
his job back no no no by the way we have
you de Paula we have to Paulo on four
okay
looking for an having to pull one so
let's talk about Kanye West again the
question what's your opinion what's your
read on the Kanye West situation for
those who don't know Kanye West through
the media into an uproar as he tweeted
out positive things about conservative
pundits any support ideas like freedom
and thought these are his unbelievably
controversial tweets now one thing
they're they're little eager to embrace
Kanye is their new thought leader which
I don't think is the best idea ah here's
the thing think whatever you want
III really don't care if you like Kanye
I've always like we used to use them as
our bumps I think he's a talented MC
he's not someone I would look to as some
kind of a new philosopher but you know
what I'm glad to see someone making some
progress and I hate to see the pig pile
on anyone for making them yeah I'm a
little concerned though I don't the mo I
swear the moment that I go in and I'm
like yes Khan is that tweets gonna come
out be like ah I was kidding man yeah
one thing that's not a joke is of course
how the left reacted and lost their mind
so that we know let's go to clip a Kanye
has lost his mind being in the lobby at
Trump's house I saw that was cool in the
new game we're starting here on Friday
Conan for cash he's a total and utter
[ __ ] he's one of the dumbest guys in
the country so dumb he's trumpian in his
level of intelligence just to understand
buyer beware Kanye West is a selfish
conservative prick he should do you mean
idea how much how quickly he would go
after anyone else for saying buyer
beware about a black person yeah Jake we
got to go after Kanye and of course the
media has been calling him a member of
the alt rights that's what's been going
on lately kanye west by the way they're
only mad at him now saying this is the
man who said he was the black jesus yes
yes so the fact that he said oh you know
what i like what some of these people on
fox news have to say this is what sends
them around over the bend you don't by
the way you don't have to defend
everything Kanye's ever done just to see
the dog pile was taking place keep in
mind this is the same guy who did say
this George Bush doesn't care about
black people
live television
anyways it doesn't matter how
inconsequential you are
everyone knows Connie is a psychopath
everyone knows like this this is the
same guy who literally married a
Kardashian is interrupted countless
Grammys and names as kids after
compasses exactly you don't know you
don't have to defend even his opinions
or or whatever he's saying you just have
to defend his right to express his
opinion freely and by the way it is
brave I will say there is some bravery
yet player because if we want to talk
about bravery slapping on a pair of fake
rubber tips well you have a still have
your penis to do a spread for Vanity
Fair
that's not brave in 2018 okay coming up
anything other than a far left
progressive is career suicide in
Hollywood it let's be honest Kanye
whether you like him or not Kanye is
still a hot ticket item in the hip-hop
community yeah so I do give respect to
the guy for going against the grain you
imagine though if someone and more
consequential came out like it like
could you imagine it's like the left
being mad that never was an bar if she
stepped out a lot well III gotta say
that bring this up like how many how
many people do you think are in that
industry that would have the same views
as Kanye but won't say it because they
know they'll just be out of the industry
right right so maybe this opens the door
for a few more people
he's just stupid you know be on a bender
who knows no and the point is I'm not
gonna condemn any conservatives who want
to embrace the guy right away but but
I'm not gonna condemn people who don't
either I'm certainly not my opinion
hasn't changed to them I do respect
someone want to take it unpopular
position now here's one thing we'll talk
and Nick DiPaolo about this I do
appreciate the lack of apology because
when you see cases like Shania Twain
apologizing for simply saying wow an
impromptu interview that she may have
voted for Trump it legitimizes the
premise that merely voting for Trump is
an apology worthy offense or jay Feely
apologizing for taking a picture with a
gun was that was a prom picture yeah
so when conservatives like well
conservatives when people like Kanye
don't apologize
it really tips the left hand as seen by
their it tips their hand when you see by
the pure vitriolic hatred yeah they
didn't ask these people to apologize for
racism okay here's one thing all the
time ago well can we get an apology they
just asked for an apology for up ooh
this is why you don't apologize unless
you genuinely believe that you are wrong
they didn't ask Kanye or Shania or feely
freely feely to apologize for racism or
for sexually inappropriate rants caught
on
they've asked them to apologize for
opinions that by the way half the
country holds the half of the country
who elects presidents true and I don't
believe for one second this would be any
less controversial if he had simply said
he doesn't mind Donald Trump no that's
the point there's there's there's
neutrality is not an option anymore so I
think it's kind of a good thing in some
ways we're seeing that that they're so
vitriolic let's just be all in for Trump
are all odds which is kind of kind of
cool and wonderful super hate him don't
expect Kanye to be apologizing anytime
soon especially if his latest mixtape is
any example I had a dream I could tweet
my own opinion of those who won't send
me all their minions I told Jake he
could eat a bag of feces man that his so
covered in grease is too black Twitter
to my views expected support Shawn King
and gage will reboot Weston seems like
he's rehashing some stuff that I
appreciate on the way from one anonymous
this has to be expected though by the
way you were going to say something girl
yeah most of the tweets weren't even
they were just saying he went he's for
free thought and free expression a few
of the tweets said he supported this
person in that person that was it
but every time people are getting pissed
off it's like man I just want my own
thoughts I want to be able to express
myself like you can't do that you're on
our team you can't this is about
defending someone's right to express a
view whether it's popular or not remove
what you think of Kanye and also look
how the Left attacks anyone who steps
out of line that's what I think is
important so right away you see Kanye
just saying okay here's a manga hat I
support Donald Trump you're gonna be
accused of being a racist we see it all
with people who are moderates like sam
harris bret weinstein he was vilified by
students roll the clip the why aren't we
gross it's racist it's not it's but it's
only so it's like saying this donate
your shifty Jew i don't care what
happens to Bret anymore he can go and be
racist and be a piece of wherever he
wants to do that hopefully long term we
can just weed out people like Breton
yeah just weed out people like Brett
weed out people like Sam Harris an
atheist who endorsed Hillary Clinton
weed out people like Kanye West who was
supportive of the Black Panthers I
believe claimed he was black Jesus but
now he stepped out in line and
supporting Trump just think of this for
a second think of what is acceptable to
the left in the entertainment industry
versus what they
find appalling it by the way let's look
at this objectively is it really that
crazy for a black person to be fed up
with the DNC in 2018 mm-hmm let's look
at this historically FDR's New Deal cost
hundreds of thousands of blacks their
jobs because of minimum wage
requirements member LBJ is the Great
Society and increased welfare payments
for single mothers and incentivize them
some people will argue that it
single-handedly started the fatherless
household epidemic you see today in the
black community and you right Brooke got
in so much trouble until member he said
I thought black people were better as a
family unit under Jim Crow than after
LBJ he didn't say he supported grow laws
he was talking about the destruction of
the family unit in the black community
which is terrible it absolutely is they
had strong marriage rates that have very
no divorce rate so and if you look at
that they've been taking the vote for
granted from Blacksburg you can watch
some black you can watch Alfonso Rachel
listen I get it I'm a white guy here you
don't necessarily care about what I had
to say but in 1965 21% of black infants
were born to single mothers okay to give
you a stat in 2016
it's almost 70 percent Wow are out of
wedlock so maybe there's a reason that
people like killer chance the rapper and
every I don't I can't get the names
right I know I'm very white no chance
the rapper and the killer my killer
might know killer Mike was the one who
stole the the microphone from Bernie I
think yeah I can't wash out every
morning large eggs large angry black men
there you run together
I don't like jockeys they try to run but
if we want to talk about more recently
black Americans they lost a huge amount
of wealth due to Obama's housing
policies race relations got worse under
Barack Obama black incomes fell by more
than nine hundred dollars per family
adjusted for inflation under President
Obama on the other hand blacks under
President Trump black unemployment at
record low their income is high the tax
cuts have helped minorities
disproportionately so just let's take
away Kanye West let's take away killer
Mike let's take away HuffPo and let's
just look objectively is it okay for
black people to step off the Democratic
plantation at this point objectively
does your honor does it hold water by
the way not to mention that if people
like us who are accused of being racist
would have their way all black Americans
would have school choice they'd have the
ability to defend themselves in areas
that are rife with gang crime we would
stop
you from killing the black babies if you
want to talk about racists okay if you
want to talk about people who are evil
it's usually not the people trying to
save black babies and give black
children the choice on where to send
their kids to school thank you for
coming in thank you for coming in thank
you think about this for a second okay
well they say you're the bad guy well in
general mad people aren't the ones
trying to turn trying to friend baby
death no no but now we say you're the
racist really you are a when we talk
about you the DNC the actual and by the
way when people people love to do this
now whether it's on YouTube or I don't
believe in labels meant no no we're
talking about the labels Lyndon Johnson
FDR Planned Parenthood Hillary Clinton
the Democratic National Committee Bernie
Sanders sorry Bernie bros who switched
to Trump you don't get to escape this
one the label is DNC Democrats that's
the label I'm being very hope I've
crystallized for you they are the party
who set out to where are the most amount
of blacks
let's set up abortion clinics so that we
can kill more blacks if you're going to
accuse people of racism it's generally
not the people going to Paul oh wait
maybe we shouldn't be using taxpayer
dollars to kill the baby blacks
maybe that's why Kanye's had enough I'm
just saying how I feel man I like Bill
Cosby ain't right no kids man
so what if I support his tax plan still
banging in Kardashian
[Music]
wait till I get my Twitter right then
you can treat me nothing right excuse me
did you tweet something nah you can't
tweet me nothing
now you can't tweet me nothing you can't
tweet me nothing
[Music]
not necessarily new content but I
appreciate his zeal Nick DiPaolo
coming up next and then they've Ruben
[Music]
[Music]
greetings America hopper here in my
silky soft we're in Japan he's available
a lot of credit shopped outcomes but
more important is that you joined mug
Club if you're a student veteran or
active military only 69 dollars a year
and if you don't join them they won't be
able to focus about otherwise me I got a
bad knee I need another knee surgery oh
my god
[Music]
you
[Music]
I never understood this in the rap
videos I'm like that's either really
inner-city thing or one hell of an ad
for selsun blue like he's permeated the
inner cities in which case they also
find themselves at odds with the Bloods
he's very very glad our next guest and
when I send this often but I mean it
there I've said this so many times for
people who haven't heard him on the show
since we've kind of grown quite a bit
since the last time he was on the show
I've always said to people I think the
funniest comedians working period alive
but probably period period know what I
think about him who make me laugh Norma
Connell and this guy I think he is the
funniest stand-up comic certainly
working today I know that's a lot of
brown-nose and you know give me crap for
it when he comes out but right now he's
going to be starting back up his own
podcast on his own YouTube channel
highly recommend you guys go and
subscribe show him your love youtube.com
slash Nick DiPaolo tube or follow him on
Twitter Nick DiPaolo PA o ello mr. de
Paula did I get those right yeah 8 p.m.
Monday night I'll be doing that 8 p.m.
Monday night ok well well then and
that's your first time back on the on
the YouTube and that's that's right
first time back yeah first a lot and
what's what's the reason for this Nick
going on the YouTube well you know I'm
sure you heard I I was canned by serious
said like so tell us about the firing so
I don't know I I tweeted something that
didn't sit well with them apparently did
I did ironically it didn't get me in
trouble on on Twitter yeah so and next
thing I know I get a call my agent go
yeah I could tell in his voice we got a
problem here
oh yeah this conversation eight times
but yeah so they thought it was a
hanging offence I personally thought you
know maybe suspension and at best but
these are the days we live in I don't
hold any grudges against serious I mean
am I disappointed in a little angry Adam
right now yeah but they're like any
other corporation they seem to fall fold
under pressure yeah I don't understand
it though they knew what they were
getting with Nick DiPaolo I mean that
your body of work is so extensive and if
you don't I want to read the tweet I
don't we were talking about this affair
when people lived on this
before we showed up like an Illinois
while we don't agree with everything
Stephen says well then shut up
I don't care I don't even by the way I
don't have any problem with what Nick
DiPaolo tweeted out so his tweet was
dear feature we have a dear future
school shooters please confine yourself
to college campuses specifically faculty
lounges at Berkeley Fresno State etc
that's my nick de Paul impression that's
funny
that's it was it was where I think I say
poorly poorly worded when I said confine
yourself to college campuses I shouldn't
you know that part my day there like you
know I could have left the college
campuses on I could have just said
faculty lounges at Berkeley but by Bob
maybe yeah I think they would have made
the inference so hypersensitive if you
read it like that it dawned on me in the
way home like 24 hours later I'm like
that part might have been well he's
encouraging we have to get over this
mentality that you put a tweet out like
that that means somebody's gonna do
something right we have to get over that
you make a gay joke that means a gay
guy's gonna get beat up tonight right
happy at the bulb of that mentality yeah
well I you know did you just see we
talked about that yesterday The Simpsons
Hank Azaria apologized for a poo the
character because the I didn't mean for
to ever hurt anyone I think the most
important thing is to listen have you
always thought that Nick the most
important thing is a stand-up comedian
is to listen and and that's our job to
listen we're psychologists I'm a
stand-up which means I shoot my mouth
off for an hour when I'm and that I do a
radio show I shoot my mouth off or
another what makes you think I even want
to listen to anybody exactly all my jobs
in Kate all my jobs involve me
controlling the conversation so but but
when you apologize like that you're
empowering the PC people are you not
know that's exactly what I said
yesterday you know what you're doing
you're empowering let's think of it as a
stand-up room and you tell me if you
agree with this or not but this was kind
of the analogy I use the rest of the
room is laughing The Simpsons immensely
successful people are not offended
HuffPo gets offended this Indian
comedian who claimed to be a comedian
made a documentary complaining about it
I don't know who he is
that's a heckler and you've now given
the head
color in the crowd as much legitimacy as
a comedian saying no no no hold on hold
on I want to hear why he's booing he has
the right to be heard I don't think they
do that's how I see it
not in a comedy club they don't they can
you know they can voice their
displeasure in social media whatever but
yeah no absolutely not not not a cartoon
ROM either not in the common adult
cartoon right right I mean you you
empower them with it with the apology
and I just don't it's just odd I didn't
I didn't really get in trouble on
Twitter and and you know I took it
fairly quickly so oh that's why I took
it down that was your mister hates it
now it's your mistake you take it's like
a t-rex their vision is based on
movement and if you take it down like oh
oh what went down and they go into the
time machine and they yes so cuz I still
get canned so I guess if I left it okay
what will they hang me no I just think
they would have liked okay that's Nick
you know I don't I don't know it's
really tough to gauge with those things
I mean I the wait yeah good you're right
and here's what makes it a little more
complicated there's a couple theories
that look my contract was up in a couple
weeks right with them so I is a one
fairy like my my agent believes and I
just made it easy for them with that
tweet let's say I didn't want to renew
me I don't think they thought the show
was gonna get as popular as it did as
quick as it did was immensely popular
for people who don't know I started at 6
p.m. and after a few months they boo me
to eight which tells me that might have
been a little scared right there right I
might have been too rough for this style
so they moved me to eight again this is
all speculation on my part but but but
it sort of makes sense either way
whether they fired me because of the
tweet or they weren't gonna renew me
anyways because of my politics either
way it's because of my believe it's
because the show was a little too rough
for them yeah well no I think I think
there's more about your polyps everyone
knows and you know Nick DiPaolo is rough
and say yeah your politics cuz here's
the deal I don't think anyone's offended
by dirty right they get to just for last
minute right the nasty show it's the
nasty show someone's gonna talk about
the vagina but the second you start
talking with some things that make
people uncomfortable politically
I mean genuinely
clinically incorrect which you do I
don't want to label you a conservative I
just think you're an anti-authoritarian
brilliant comic I think that's what they
have a problem with more I don't think
they were surprised at the roughness I
think they were surprised at how
outspoken you were politically and
culturally that's what bothers them
that's what advertisers shy away from
well leaning leaning write writing with
my [ __ ] yeah I I kind of agree with that
again I'm not I'm not bitter it's
serious I'm gonna get mad at you they
gave me an opportunity I'm gonna use it
as a springboard right this missed
opportunity because come on this is I'm
gonna go to work for myself and and
right and you know even Joe Rogan texts
me saying how angry he was you know and
a few other people so and then he
offered he was saying to Mt the
possibilities of what you cannot do I do
an Advil PM and I'm screwed up I'll
never understand that yeah I know
I loved I love Joe but you know what I
used to coach jiu-jitsu I'd have kids
come in and they'd come in and they'd go
like yeah Mon DM team like what because
cuz Eddie Bravo said that it was better
to roll it opened your mind I'm like oh
my god please don't do that someone and
then next thing you know he's being tied
up like a pretzel someone's breaking his
arm
gradually he ends up with a black belt
around his neck in his closet yes
exactly it's it's the David Carradine
submission it's an effective no see I
could have gotten fired if I'd had done
that somewhere else but I can't because
I'm on YouTube so where can people go to
watch you on YouTube it's youtube.com
slash Nick DiPaolo tube that's correct
Nick DiPaolo tube and I assume you're
also gonna be doing it on iTunes and
kind of getting it out on different
platforms yeah it's good and I don't
even know that that's gonna be the final
resting place of the show right but you
know Monday night is is is where I'm
first time I'll be back since this
incident was serious but I don't add as
many options I have many options so yeah
I don't know that that's gonna be the
final landing point is something called
what is it
patreon yeah you heard it like I've
heard a patreon yeah I'm not I'm not a
fan just because there's a bunch of
hobos over there it's basically like the
online
yet some people's legitimate enterprises
and he have hobos with their cup out
like hey I want to do a show where I
talk about the subplots of Game of
Thrones like get the hell out of here
really a nerd landing spot whatever
there's this um but not I don't know
where it where it's gonna end I I would
like to you know keep it on YouTube or
whatever and get it out to my I'm gonna
treat it just like the radio show I'm
gonna do it like you know four nights a
week and and treat it like the radio
show well you're you're a consummate
professional I will say that you know
listen you're it you're a comedian and
comedians are typically known for being
lazy and waking up you know at noon
looking for the the leftover drugs Nick
is very professional he always has been
you've always had a love for traditional
radio I've always known I woke up Blaine
looking for the drugs I found my liquid
floor yes
you saw the Advil PM it's put it back
put it back that's for that's for later
well we have a party at Nick where can
people see you live here coming up to it
froze up oh I fall there we go this is a
this is a new media yeah this weekend I
don't know I give it to you right now I
did my homework thank you guys all this
stuff I know okay I have it I have it
Nick is right I have this that's the
name of the comedy tour or and I don't
know exactly what but people can
obviously go to a pet Pottsville
Pennsylvania tonight I mean Friday night
excuse me okay and the Kirby Center in
wilkes-barre Pennsylvania on Saturday
night so Nick dip calm slashed over
people who want to see all of the dates
coming up but you know listen don't let
the bad I mean I know okay either you
probably some friends there but I think
this is a good thing and Nick DiPaolo
deserves to be the audience deserves to
hear Nick DiPaolo unfiltered Unleashed
absolutely well I thought that's what
satellite I guess I'm naive sure what at
one point it was for about ten minutes
yeah again I'm not I'm not I'm not you
know I'm not crapping on their product
I'm disappointed I thought to be some
more backbone there but I fright
tomorrow night the Majestic Theatre in
Platteville Pennsylvania in Pottsville
Pennsylvania and the Kirby Center in
wilkes-barre Pennsylvania and the next
weekend Jonathan's in a gunk with Maine
and Shuba theater New Haven
on May 5th okay idle day doublet or pots
no pots yeah that's not the name of the
town where the where the pharmacist
crushed the eustachian tube and it's a
wonderful life of the kid with the
pharmacy was a goddess Pottersville yeah
it's it's just it's all wonderful in
general no I could imagine that I would
have thought you remember at one point
when when satellite came out that's what
people thought it was going to be and I
can just picture Nick walking in and
being disappointed like well I thought I
was gonna be unfiltered what do you put
me next to dr. Laura Schlessinger and
the $4 of Howard Stern where the
producers like their balls on fire what
am i what am i doing like it really is a
weird mix on satellite well you know
it's funny they movement when they move
me to 8 o'clock the building is empty
except for the studio next to me which
is shade 45 it's all these black guys
every night it's a bunch of and look at
this 14 guys in a studio they got they
got the mirror glasses on and there's
always something like prostitute looking
chick why don't I faint sore not are
they granting an ottoman you know I'd
run it like I'd went to the I go to use
the men's room it's surrounded by three
black as with San Jose Jersey shirts on
you know what did you ever find out what
that was
I had no idea and boy I'd always look in
when I walk by and you'd see 12 heads
look at me apparently they knew my
material look in there I like keep going
white yeah not so tough now that Patrice
ain't here huh
there you go adept about a joke about a
comedian who died well get in trouble
for that one too also was really funny
Patricio he was great and I always
wonder what a lot of people like that
back you don't want it you never want to
talk for someone who's not here but what
they would think about the state of
comedy where people are apologizing let
me ask you this final question because
we're talking about this yesterday with
the Appu situation and you know now Amy
Schumer's latest film where she's out
talking about how it's just the goal is
to empower women while you make a bunch
of fat jokes and then at the end say
it's okay do you genuinely if you were
to look and you have to grade it comedy
in 2018 it's pretty easy for people we
cut week
certainly our our sort of set point is
to [ __ ] about the good old days but do
you think that comedy in 2018 is in a
worse place than it was 10 20 years ago
it depends like what your act is I enjoy
I enjoy making people crying not
laughing with is upset um and but I was
ahead of the curve I was making people
upset at the Comedy Cellar 10-15 years
ago but yes I mean we're a hike its
hypersensitive what the problem now
Steve and I see Laura Lee's comedy clubs
which I'm not playing right now these
are nice theater venues but a lot of
these comedy clubs now being run by
people who have grown up you know
Millennials have grown up with this PC
atmosphere and it's in their DNA right I
hear tommix getting in trouble for doing
rape jokes at a club or whatever that's
that's danger I mean this that's
dangerous so I would say yeah but I but
I sort of enjoy going against the grain
I always did not intentionally that that
was just my in my DNA right you know but
I'm not back in the clubs right now
which you know I will be I I gotta make
a living but I would say yeah it's a
little I don't like where it's headed
well that's a good point that's all
right I never I talked with Joe Rogan
about that and he didn't agree and I
said listen you know you have a bit of a
blind spot Joe because you're very
successful I said you understand it's
not just about the audience it's about
the people it's about the gatekeepers
now who aren't going to take that risk
on a young Nick DiPaolo today on a young
Steven there's no way I could get stage
time in an open mic with what we do
there's no possible way I could get
started today because the club just
isn't going to take the risk you know
you used to tell rape jokes and used
used to commit rape in a club and it was
it was funny if it was on the right
night you could crush and bring in tons
of people but just all it takes is one
person all it takes is one person to
complain one person with one rape
whistle and you well a little known fact
about rape whistles it's actually a good
dog it's actually a very high pitch it
just calls more rapists so in the end
it's actually one one for the rapists
put one up on the board for cause yeah
yeah so yeah I think the answer your
question yeah I don't like where it's
headed and and what makes me sick is
when you go online and you read like
young comics defending this PC point of
view well the guy made a documentary
that the Simpsons changeup ooh and by
the way did you know this now you can't
say Indian I just found this out it's
South Asian American are you aware of
that no I'm not and I will not change
any but I actually said you know who
cares I say Indian when I'm talking
about Native American that's when they
really get pissed yeah just stick with
Indians
what do you mean 'i'm on stage my last
show for this tour i want to ride on
stage like the guy does before the
Florida State football games that come
in on that pony yeah I got the head
dress on and I slam that flaming arrow
into the stage there you know exactly no
I think you're like I roll on it
apparently that's the key to go viral
yeah you know I have to I don't I throw
a puppy into a fireplace and anything to
get you know eyes on you know if you
throw a cat into a fireplace you get
defended for murder like Steven Avery
and making a murder they glossed over
that part but you have one tweet like
Nick DiPaolo and you get let go from
Sears but I will say this your loss is
everybody else's gain youtube.com slash
Nick DiPaolo tube please go to Nick dip
comm slash tor and yeah I agree just
just call them Indians and then
Orientals let's continue with that Nick
please come back sooner I thought you
were cross with me because you weren't
on for so long so I'm glad job no no
good
please I have plenty plenty of people to
be legitimately mad about not you well I
know but you're a touchy [ __ ] we never
know how it's gonna be good looking in
the remind me of me a few years it kind
of bugs me that actually no you're
selling yourself sure I will say this
Nick DiPaolo is a good-looking man and
for his age if you saw Nick DiPaolo when
he was in his 20s it was like Elvis
Presley he's about as good-looking as a
man has ever walked this earth Nick
DiPaolo I'm very very jealous
that's what Patricia yeah you're bright
looking okay Nick DiPaolo youtube.com
slash Nick DiPaolo tube and we'll be
back of this thank you sir I'm looking
forward to seeing from you
there it is again so strong
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to wild at large on the Nature
Network narrated by Jasper prawns the
lion king of the jungle in inspiration
to many tales both young and old the
lion inspires power and fear in the
hearts of those who see it here we see
the line and its natural mating habitat
oh boy look at that that that line is
hung like well the lion I guess cut
damage at what what am i living here you
know I'm giving it my own spin for the
viewer stick to the script you can't
talk about lion
Jasper well that's what I'm saying
maybe we should change that stay tuned
for more world at large on the Nature
Network narrated by Jasper prawns
[Music]
be surprised how effective as a
grown-man palm straw bit its to palm
shop really talk about my first physical
altercation as an adult male but the
person listening knows exactly the point
is I brought guns to a nunchuck fight
yeah I want you brought guns I had a
switchblade which was given to me that
night as a gift and I handed it to my
father and said please hold this as I'm
about to proceed to kick this man's ass
and thank thank goodness Johnny boy
diffused it you did doesn't make me feel
any less worse about it also filter
weather our next guest he just he just
keeps bumping and bumping and he's he's
so in demand he's so difficult and now
he has the beard because he wants to
make himself seem more like a mountain
man I don't know what's going on with
him you know him
Rueben report on the Twitter and of
course on the YouTube very popular show
Ruben report Dave Rubin how are you sir
Crowder what's happening man your hair
is shorter on the side and longer kind
of have the not gay Jerrod haircut now I
just got my hair cut within the hour
this is Lee this is a seriously fresh
tight situation I'm going on tour with
Peterson so I had to get the hair cut
before we head out of town now what's a
tour with Peterson like what do you do
so this Jordan Peterson guy i I know you
are slightly aware of him did you do
Stan cuz I needed stand-up before are
you doing stand-up like introducing him
and then he's like yeah I got it kind of
got two things going on so we with
Jordan I'm opening for him kind of doing
10 15 minutes of stand-up maybe for some
of them will do a sit down together cuz
the guys doing about thirty five of
these and it's a lot to take in to just
talk for two and a half hours so
hopefully I can take take some of the
burden off him on that but you will be
very proud and I think you're one of the
people that dragged me back into this
kicking and screaming I did my first
hour of stand-up about a week and a half
ago at the Irvine improv sold-out
standing ovations and the manager there
said in her 18 years she's never seen a
sold-out standing ovation so we just
booked DC improv Tempe improv and I'm
just gonna be bouncing around and I was
I wasn't the one who dragged you into
that I told that I told you to stay away
yeah I was a TEFL I think you're
confusing me with with your father or
mother or some perhaps or perhaps your
your lover also named Dave I was
incredibly unsupportive but I'm glad to
hear what
well I assure you that can stand up
well no listen I'm glad if you'd have
put that in the in the in the the
outline I could have bragged for you so
that way you know you would have been it
would have been a better like a standing
O but would you like I got a standing O
there ones like oh yeah but that's okay
see if when he says it but I'm glad so
you're doing more stand-up normally I
wouldn't do that but I was just you know
after stepping away it was my first hour
in 10 years yeah I'm feeling good and
also you know with this Kanye thing the
whole world is upside down right now and
I'm very energetic I couldn't here's the
thing we're talking about
I couldn't care less about Kanye himself
whether people liked him or not he's not
a savior he's not a modern philosopher
as they said on Fox & Friends for me
it's all about a the truth
and the reaction from the left they're
asking him to apologize not for anything
racist nothing's asked him to apologize
for supporting Donald Trump aren't we
vindicated now because we said don't
apologize it's not about the racism it's
not about the sexism it's just about
anything that you disagree with
yeah well prouder I gotta tell ya I'm
more of a Frank Sinatra Dean Martin guy
than I am say honey a West guy I would
have guessed cher but those work too I
do I have never met a lesbian who did
not like Melissa Etheridge I know you
don't run in the same circles
but here's I will say in my life I've
never met one they all every time I said
I woke up I'm like hi I'm Stephen I'm
drew Wow we know this happened what was
happening what was happening at the
window did she have a pie I mean what
there's a joke there no here we go go
I agree with you look I don't know a ton
about Kanye beyond the cultural
relevance of Kanye and the you know the
George Bush thing during Katrina and
some of that stuff I'm not a huge it's
just not my kind of music per se but
some of its pretty good i david had me
playing the the one the the one that he
did with Daft Punk is pretty cool okay
whatever yeah but she actually do think
he is a modern-day philosopher in that
this is someone that yes he may not be
the greatest philosopher of all time but
he can truly move minds with his words
and for all of us for whatever little
political differences we have for all of
us that for these last couple years have
been banging and banging and banging
against this political correct nonsense
this lunacy from the left is cultural
Marxism and collectivism and all that
this is what we needed now we shouldn't
be worshipping the guy I have no idea
what his politics are but he just gave a
ton of oxygen to the space that we've
been operating in and we needed oxygen
there so I think I truly think this
thing is massive but yes we cannot treat
him like some sort of political hero or
some you know anything like that I'm
here not a we this does not sound like a
classical liberal Democrat thing a lot
of wheeze yeah a lot of we I don't know
you want freedom I mean with you there
you go okay there you go we so we're
we're collectivists as it relates to
individualism of individualist
no but I understand I'm actually a big
Kanye West fan we used to use the last
bump before we did the drowning dance
which will do here shortly
was the car and it's out to the fans to
see if they can remember it was a Kanye
West song every single episode before we
went to YouTube because then it was a
copyright issue that we had to actually
get clearance from Pogo and I think
Andrew W K and a few artists so I've
always been a Kanye fan actually I've
always said he's a dumbass but he's a
brilliant emcee and my opinion has not
changed at all I think he's a dumbass
but I think they're a lot of dumb ass
liberals and a lot of dumb ass
conservatives and I think that you know
what it's a lot more brave we just
talked about this for him to come out
and say what he said then slap on a fare
of fake rubber tits and get on the cover
of Vanity Fair so good on him for going
against the grain of course and you know
the irony here is that this isn't that
you have to be a trump supporter because
you like Kanye or something like that
the the point is that the intellectual
hostage-taking
that we all know about that we've been
screaming about this lunacy that is that
is infected colleges that is infected
the media that has affected the
political establishment that Trump kind
of you know beat on for heard these last
couple years
Kanye just opened the door he opened the
door for you to say you know what I'm a
little different and maybe that isn't
because guys like us are the biggest fan
of him but he speaks to another segment
of the population that needed to hear it
and I think that these people on the
Left they're followers and the second
they see that make that it's okay to
think a little bit differently they're
gonna break in huge numbers yeah and he
might have just opened the door because
he's an axe to grind over Barack Obama
calling him a jackass it could have been
as simple in narcissistic as half of
Donald Trump really tweets but if it
allows other people either brother Trump
cuz Trump is saying the
I think I think it's that White House
correspondent airs really set Trump off
the presidency nope you're exactly right
so I'm curious to see what the fallout
is from this absolutely we just had Nick
DiPaolo on the show who's just fired
from Sirius XM for a tweet which was
really pretty mild about school
shootings you just saw Hank Azaria
apologize for a pillow on The Simpsons I
mean to me what's so got to go I don't
have a ton of time but to me the biggest
problem is now the left has empowered
hecklers they've said well you have to
listen to them just as much if there's
one person offended and they've actually
empowered hecklers who are offended from
content retro actively 25 years ago like
The Simpsons
what we're supposed to apologize for
something that wasn't allowed today for
25 years ago I mean how come there's no
possible way anyone can come out
unscathed but this nonsense is coming to
an end you know Hank Azaria I went on a
little Twitter tirade
I admire this guy I think he's wickedly
talented he does about 30 voices on The
Simpsons he's probably the greatest
voiceover actor of all time the idea
that he would apologize for this
character a character who taught the
Simpsons about immigration who had an
Indian wedding yeah he's one of of
Homer's crew he is hard-working he's
everything that's right about America
and that they tricked him that this SJW
mob tricked him while his Hank and a
giveaway all the the 400 grand an
episode he gets to do up who I suspect
not yeah I want like I don't respect him
and I'll tell you why I don't respect
him because a good friend of mine voices
many characters in The Simpsons I've
talked about I can't use her name
because she's been in the closet as a
conservative and she's been chastised by
not just Hank Azaria I forgot his name
the guy guy in all the Christopher
guest's movies the guy does a Principal
Skinner SNL Harry Shearer Harry Shearer
Harry Shearer mr. elitist left us this
woman who is one of the biggest Carol
reactions on The Simpsons you he she
does so many characters you go that's
her that's her that's her she has to be
quiet because of the Hank Azaria's and
the Harry shears chastising her in the
studio so you know what a season
crocodiles is futile they've now come
for him instead of apologizing he should
come out and say I was wrong blank to
that I don't want to use this lady's
name I was wrong I'm sorry for doing to
you what they're doing to me instead
they're trying to toss their lot and to
save their career that's why I have more
respect for
for Kanye West at least unlike Hank
Azaria he's not apologizing and I think
Hank Azaria is more talented than Kanye
West but Kanye doesn't give a crap for
the record I meant I respect his talent
that's not the decision here obviously
but this but that's why what I did was I
said a couple tweets out and then I said
Hank I hope you'll come sit down with me
or get him to sit down you crowder
because we can wake these guys up the
mob will never stop there is nothing you
can give them that the mob goes oh well
I guess we won and we're gonna move on
no the mob will destroy everything right
and if we let the idea that up who was
somehow a racist character or the simple
fact that Indian Americans are either
number one or two at almost every
socio-economic way we can grade things
if we throw that away because of some
silly jokes it really it's it takes down
the fabric of what America let's be
clear Kanye West was at was asked to
apologize for supporting for maybe
opening the door to supporting Donald
Trump The Simpsons were asked to
apologize for creating a character who
was a legal immigrant and successful
business owner no apologies as Andrew
Breitbart said apologized for what the
Reuben report Reuben report on Twitter
good to see you sir I know you're busy
we'll have to talk with you soon we have
more time Crowder do you know how many
times I'm gonna like to apologize for
just appearing with you don't apologize
just tell them to go to tell sensor
button tell him to go for cells with a
wire brush I'll see you later Dave Rubin
thank you very much wrap up the show
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to wild at large on the Nature
Network narrated by Jasper pranks the
Black Widow the mere name strikes fear
and those of all who hear and oft
misunderstood and one of nature's most
dangerous creatures the Black Widow
finds itself in the exclusive position
of being one of the few species where
the female picks her male mate as you
see here the heated dance of sexuality
is one of nature's most cruel tricks
unlike most animals or insects the black
widow is the one who takes firm control
of the sexual direction picking her male
mate and as you see here amidst actual
copulation she begins to devour her male
mate I tell you what it doesn't sound
all that different from my ex-wife cut
damn it Jasper stay tuned for more wild
at large on the Nature Network narrated
by Jasper prawns
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes you gotta kick off your face
is really red my face is really rather
good actually really got strawberry
because it by the way thank you to Dave
Rubin for being on the show
mmm-hmm lovely little sprite always
always having him it was like it's been
like breathing through a straw this
entire week so for people who don't know
I it was actually the first time we've
ever missed a show just because I was so
sick yeah whose day sure we miss shows
before because they've had technical
difficulties or it's like I listen I
just can't make it there on time I was
that's my first sick day sick sick sick
sick day in the history of the show
turns out of a double I have a sinus
infection in a bronchial infection hmm
and it sounds like code for super aids
no it sounds like some super age and
I've been drinking that probiotics and
stuff like it's going out of style
because apparently you know when you
take the anti I haven't at antibiotics
in like years yeah
so apparently when you take antibiotics
you got to replace the bad bacteria with
the good bacteria I could tell from
experience it's not pleasant if you
don't it's very bad it just but it
tastes like some you know like you want
to taste like remember in The Wizard of
Oz where the Tin Man couldn't and they
old them it tastes like what he would
excrete after you oiled him that's what
bit layer with that remember just how
much I paid too important an ungodly
country so you can feel better trimmer
during the break that actually was a
really good point I had a my point was
with the Konya thing what really bothers
me is people like to HuffPo and salon
and slay they like to go off about toxic
masculinity toxic white in this toxic
white privilege white privilege I mean
they go on and on and something I think
is far more toxic people talk about for
the for the country is this idea that
the left side eeeh of totalitarianism in
all things well not on I would rephrase
it not the left idea totality rien is
over the left doesn't realize it's a
night yeah it doesn't even realize right
does not realize this idea but they have
no room for anybody to step outside the
box but you think it's so harming people
that's where you have these situations
where Kanye's like well then all all and
then yeah big Trump mugga the only thing
to think is toxic as toxicity itself and
then that Armenian going that talks
about yeah I cannot believe the system
of it down ever
chili was a ban you think jinx just met
Akane because he can't mow down his wife
for being Armenian I do I'd pay a nickel
to see that catfight i Kasparian and kim
kardashian we were like when Yokozuna I
used to do the but the Rishi but flop
and then and get then gold dust was just
making out with men hold hands it
snorkel copper ass yeah let's do this
bring your country back together no you
can't it's not off the ice off the hip
bones it needs to be a stable surface we
have some pretty big videos coming up
for you pretty soon
by the way tomorrow we're gonna have a
review on the Avengers gonna be yeah on
The Avengers which I'm not looking
forward to seeing but I've seen your
you're a miserable superhero movie fan
no I'm not here's the thing I have
certain superhero movies that I really
like Logan I liked I actually liked
x-men first class Deadpool I loved the
Dark Knight series I really like if you
gonna go to more like a popcorn
family-friendly I think spider-man 2
with Alfred Molina is dr. poetry that's
that was fantastic the news spider-man's
not well the new news spider-man's cuz
it then they did it with Garfield those
weren't good then the newest Spiderman
was not very good no because I thought
he in them was pretty good I thought he
was a good Peter Parker he was fine but
it's their overall writing and kind of I
I'm just tired and done with CGI monster
villains I think that's one thing that
made certain films we talked about some
more tomorrow but some films like
Christopher Nolan's much more they care
just much about the villain go to
Chicago or its burger you can go that's
well that's what that's where they flip
ya know there is I do have a lot of I
think Nolan is about gimmicky but I do
have a lot of respect for him
so hopefully listen you can you can come
back and check on our review on the
Avengers a lot of people been asking for
more film reviews they find them pretty
helpful I know a lot of people are upset
at the lack of diversity in the Marvel
films right now we don't care so I you
know I think it's a really good point
though that you brought up not gay
jeered white privilege to masculine now
I'm losing the term man toxic
masculinity
what's toxic is I did is is
totalitarianism
what's toxic is finding a guy because
his dog did a Nazi salute
what's toxic is putting a guy before
Human Rights Tribunal because he's a
comedian he made a joke
what's toxic is ruining sitcoms making
them apologize for
stereotype which is uniquely
pro-american in a realm of shows that
don't have a lot of pro-american foreign
stereotypes that really is what's toxic
what's toxic is people telling you how
to think and what to think and you know
what we almost did it this if you go
back that's why I said you know what
think whatever you want
because I don't want people to take what
I'm saying as well you have to think
that way
I think Kanye's kind of a jackass I have
initially bought it I think he might be
doing this because Barack Obama called
him a jackass and he's been he's been
seething on that I don't think Kanye is
necessarily someone who should be the
arbiter of it anything political but I
hate to see someone get jumped on and
I'm not going to tell you what you
should think about Kanye West if you
want to embrace him if you think let's
give this guy a chance because we need
everyone we can get we really only had
heidi montag and scott baio we'll take a
Kanye West go ahead go for it and if you
say hey I'm gonna hold him at arm's
length that's fine
go for it too I just think it's
important to recognize what's happening
and I think more important sometimes
than what someone says a lot of it'll
get cut off with caught up and whether
they like the person or not yeah sure
that's irrelevant kind of like when we
were you know we did these shows like at
Illinois I love it the SMU Republicans
could because they didn't care right
they were just amazing probably the best
group we'd ever worked with really funny
but an Illinois writer when people start
protesting to go well and we don't agree
with everything Stephen says first off
shut up okay cuz if you're bringing the
ladder with Crider show in you brought
us in you're already in it now
apologizing this you know we saw it
because people tonight apologized as a
Canadian for saying she might have voted
for Trump so you don't need to do that
you know what he said well we don't
agree with okay
let's remove this aspect of it let's
remove the person maybe you don't like
me maybe you don't like na kijiye and
maybe I don't like Kanye West as a
person but you can remove that your
personal support or disdain by the way
it applies to hero-worship same thing
with president Donald Trump and look at
how people are treating that person or
look at the reaction from society at
large and when people try to tell you
that this is how you need to think or
this is how you need to react the real
reason they are asking Kanye West to
apologize is because he's black it's
because he's black and he needs to think
a certain way what could possibly be
more toxic in 2018 than telling a black
man you have to think and speak this way
otherwise we're going to revoke
your black card seriously yeah I don't
even care about Kid Rock as much no they
don't and that's why when we talk we'd
always come back to this and I know Ben
Shapiro talks about it as well
that's why we've seen so many stars in
both the left and right movement rise
and fall because it's just based on the
controversy and we could go after the
controversy right now and say Kanye West
yes absent behind a bone not we could
have gone obsession we wish you had
better represent Hollywood had better
representative Tom Hanks somebody we
could have gone in and said Donald Trump
he's the second coming of Christ slash
Reagan but we didn't we were honest
about it because at the end of the day
being truthful is more valuable you know
sometimes we this week we had some a
week where a couple of people said you
know I feel like you're not as
passionate about some of these topics
because there's a lot of a lot of comedy
this week first off I was at death's
door secondly I didn't really care so
I'm honest with you if you see me get
pissed about something if you see me get
passionate about something that's
because it's truthful I don't want to
line something up on the prompter and
tell you how it's gonna be because I'm
gonna do a rant on my Facebook page
every day the truth I believe is
important about and I think comedy is a
great way to tell the truth it's a great
way Phyllis Diller said it's a rubber
tip sword it's a way to make a point
without drawing blood and the truth
right now doesn't center around how you
personally feel about someone like a
Kanye West it doesn't sit around how you
personally feel about Shania Twain
doesn't center around how you personally
feel about feely with a picture of a gun
doesn't doesn't Center on how you
personally feel about Donald Trump the
truth is something that needs to be
removed regardless of circumstance
regardless of the personality attached
to that situation we've been dealing
with that this week sometimes it's down
like well this story doesn't really
matter that much I mean it doesn't
matter if you're watching this show if
we taught there's some truth hopper is
uh is not on drugs at the truth hopper
squirrel policy hopper squirrel
there you go see a lot of y'all think
he's dead he's not dead I know if they
sound like a broken record truth matters
so much more than trying to score points
and I see people jump in sides to Kanye
and they could be embarrassed and I see
some people making fun of Kanye and they
could be embarrassed just like we saw it
with a lot of other conservative
firebrands remember where people just
jumped and oh this is a black
conservative who spoke oh this is a
fourteen-year-old conservative who's
force and they scream
guess what if you say hey I like what
this kid said in this instance or if you
say hey you know what I like what Kanye
said here hey you know what I find it
really reprehensible how people are
treating him here without saying I'm
going for Kanye and a foam finger guess
what you save yourself a lot of
embarrassment down the world down the
road and guess what and you don't have
to apologize that's another thing in a
world where everyone demands apologies
that's somewhere I'd like to see some
more truths and that's why I appreciate
Nick DiPaolo yeah like I said remember
this they will ask you to apologize for
anything so what the next time you see a
store where they say well he needs to
apology that was out of line it did seem
a little bit racist they're not asking
these people to apologize for racism for
sexism for homophobia
they're asking Kanye West to apologize
for posting a manga hat they're asking
Shania Twain to apologize for saying
she'd vote for Donald Trump and by the
way I don't even necessarily know that I
agree or disagree with these statements
so when people apologize they come out
or Hank Azaria says I'm sorry about it
Boop
he's not sorry about it Boop guess what
you and I both know Shania Twain is
probably not that sorry that she said in
an impromptu interview I guess I would
have voted for Donald Trump so I do
respect Kanye West for not apologizing I
do respect Nick DiPaolo for not
apologizing I tell my wife this almost
if I apologized just so that I could not
have to sleep on the couch which doesn't
happen I'm a grown-ass man I don't go
and sleep on the couch of a king-size
bed I just get you over one foot but I
always tell my wife you would not
appreciate me you would not respect me
and the apologies would be meaningless
if you knew they were untruthful so
let's be truthful on how we handle the
news and how we disseminate the news and
how outraged we get about the news and
let's be truthful with their apologies
no more apology tours because I don't
even know what apologies are true so if
you're an apology from me or from not
gay Jared then you know it must be
really bad we'll see you next week buh
see you tomorrow Avengers
[Music]